wilden recently asked what if i want to
access my private google cloud storage
from cloudround
in a previous video i described how to
read and write regular files from
cloudrun now let's talk about how to
access a google sheet from cloudrun your
servers might need to read some manually
entered data or write a report for
example
first find the service account that your
cloud run service is using click the
cloud round revision and then security
if the account listed looks like an
email copy that otherwise look up the
account's email address under im
now go to your sheet click share and
enter that email address give it editor
or viewer access
next install the google api client
library in your dev environment then
import that library in your code pull in
the default credentials and read or
write rows in the sheet
check the description below for links to
the reference docs
in a future episode i will talk about
how to let the user pick one of their
google sheets at runtime